what is going on everybody welcome to my
tutorial on how to use Twitter's API or
version 1.1 to access streaming tweets
within Python my previous Twitter
tutorials were showing you how to parts
Twitter basically without using
Twitter's API and there's a multitude of
reasons why you'd want to do this but
also I'm sure a lot of people just want
to parse Twitter using or just pull from
Twitter using Twitter's API and the API
is actually a pretty good API that said
the documentation on Twitter is while
extremely extensive there's also like
really confusing and maybe it's kind of
confusing because it is so extensive I
don't know or maybe I just suck at
reading documentation either way if
you're in that same boat as me I've got
a video for you so my goal here in this
video is just in this first video to go
completely from scratch where we are
right now to streaming data in Python
and then from there I'll have some
future videos on how to manipulate this
data also I've had a lot of requests for
reading Arabic Chinese and some other
stuff within Python so probably some
videos on that as well so stay tuned for
those so anyway how do we actually get
started so the first thing that you're
gonna want to do is take yourself you
know open up whatever browser you're
using and go to dev Twitter comm from
there you're gonna want to sign in to
your account my case sent Dex password
one two three four five so once you log
in it should look a little bit something
like this and what we want to do is
actually add our applications so
probably the best way to do this is go
over to your user over here and click on
my applications wait for that to load up
and you can see I already have an
application here but you might you
probably don't so click on create a new
application and when you do that you're
gonna want to enter in all of the
various details to this application so
in my case we're gonna call this I guess
we'll just call it Twitter feed so your
application
and then here description stream of
twitter is what we'll call it website
this is gonna be with syntax com
you don't need to put a callback URL yet
come down here agree to their terms and
then do one of these impossible CAPTCHAs
let's wait until I can find one this one
looks okay and then create the
application hopefully with the CAPTCHA
right not a valid you okay HTTP colon
slash slash syntax that you know what I
like about Twitter if there's nothing
else I like about Twitter it's that we
got the capture right but we screwed up
something else in the forum and we don't
have to do another CAPTCHA that's great
every website needs to adopt this oh my
goodness Twitter feed has already been
taken for an okey dokey so somebody else
already has that so we'll just call it a
you whitey Twitter feed yay oh my
goodness this is quite possibly the
hardest application I've ever had to
make
okay great we've got YouTube feed good
we made the application and as you can
see we do have a whole like a consumer
key and consumer secret but the other
thing that we need is these access
tokens so the next thing you'll want to
do is come down here say yeah create my
access token so you just click on that
and then it'll say boom you've got you
know some sort of token that was created
if you oh it takes a moment to take
effect then in a second we should see it
let's refresh there we go so now we have
our access token and then our access
token secret great so now what do we do
with this well the next thing that we
want to do is actually use well you need
this to connect to their Twitter feed so
what we're going to go ahead and do now
though is download tweet Pete for
accessing this Twitter feed well like I
was saying before I mean there's there's
a bunch of different imports that you
can use to do this tweet peas just one
of them I did I went through about four
of them and Twiggy seem to be the most
towards what we are doing here now if
you're gonna actually make an
application with it it might make sense
to go with one of the other one so just
keep that in mind
so anyway sweepy how do we get it well
go to google and type in tweet P Python
so I'm gonna do that let's open up
another tab and I'm here like I was
saying Tweety Python and we'll go to the
github
now of course depending on you know what
kind of operating system you're on and
all that how you download this might
vary I'm gonna go ahead and just
download the zip also if you didn't
already install it or you don't know how
to install it and you want to do it the
same way I've been doing it or I do it
if you open up the file you'll see that
there's a setup duck PI file in there so
we need to do is navigate to this file
and then you just do Python setup I
install so I'll just show you that real
quick
so in here you would CD to desktop / 3 P
2 and then all you really need to do
from here is Python setup that py
install and I've already installed tweet
piece so I'm not going to do that but
that is what you would do and that would
install all the files as long as Python
is in your path if you don't know what
that means leave a comment below and
I'll help ya so anyway that's that once
you have creepy installed you should be
able to go to your python interpreter so
there's open up a Python command line
wow that's bright
but anyway import we P should be
possible for you if it throws an error
something went wrong in the installation
process if you can't figure it out go
ahead and leave a comment below
otherwise if you can't figure it out
continue on so I close out of this and
this and now we're gonna actually make
our script now I'm gonna go ahead and
delete these because I don't need these
either I lied I want it back what we're
gonna have to do open it up real quick
and just kind of like look thick
sometimes it's helpful to look through
your documentation a great place to
start is probably examples and stuff but
you can like look at all of their code
in here especially so we're gonna be
using streaming so if you
in the streaming you can see that you
know you've got a stream listener on
connect on data on status to leave limit
air all this stuff you have all this in
here that you can use we're only going
to use on data and error but just so you
know they're all here that you can use
what else there was one more thing I
wanted to show you guys as far as like
what you can put in here we go so you
can also filter things and so here you
can filter by locations async tracking
track can be like a specific term stuff
like that
follow can be people and so on so anyway
we're going to I'll show you an example
in a moment so now we want to do let me
close out of this and we're done here I
think as well and I really am going to
delete this now and bring over this
tutorial here there we go okay so now
we've got this window here and this is
where we're gonna actually create our
script let me see one real quick alright
I'm in my font a little bigger so
hopefully it's easier to see so now we
need to import three things for our
script so we need frong to EP wow that's
pretty big to import stream and actually
mean stream with a capital S from tree P
in 400 handler pay attention to the
casing there and then finally from twe P
Diet streaming import stream listener
now we'll come down here and now let's
go ahead and define a few things the
things that we're going to need
immediately are gonna be the consumer
key what are those the consumer secret
the access token and then the access
secret so we need all these things where
are they
well I just showed you so what you want
to do is pop back over to Twitter for
example here's my Twitter and let me
just squeeze this over so stream listen
ok so scroll down and you'll see ok well
here's our consumer key so we'll just
copy and paste that your should be
different than mine if it's the same
that's odd consumer secret and then back
down here now access token and then the
access secret and then we're done with
Twitter now so so now we've got our
variables that we need next thing we
need to do is define our listener class
and it's basically a lot like what we've
just seen in that the documentation
files basically actually like the files
it wasn't documentation there might be a
better way to go about doing this but
this is the way I figured it out so the
way we're going to do it so anyway class
listener in here we're gonna say stream
and then in here we're gonna have that
on data and on air that you saw just a
moment ago so we're gonna say define on
data so they go and then all we want to
do is print out whatever that data is
turn true otherwise define on-air again
a parent so status and then we just want
to print the status like whatever the
air is so a lot of times you might give
will I'll show you that in a little bit
will force an air so the next thing we
want to do now is we need to authorize
ourselves so to do this it's pretty
simple off equals and then we have to
use the OAuth Handler and do this we use
our consumer key and our consumer secret
and it's doing all kinds of fancy stuff
in the background that you don't have to
worry about auth dot set underscore
Access underscore token and here again
we do a token and a secret finally we do
Twitter stream the equals stream pay
attention to the capital S there ah
listener and that's obviously referring
to this listener right here that we made
and then finally our last line that we
need is our filter so we're going to say
Twitter stream filter and what do we
want to filter by wil Wheaton's like
track equals I'm gonna put in car here
so basically every message with car in
it we're gonna spit that out so let's go
ahead and save that and we will run it
now and hopefully not having any massive
errors ah we did have an air handler
learn to spell dummy again okay and
because my font is just massive it's
hard for me to drag this over oh my
goodness
anyway it's kind of big Fox I made it
for this video but as you can see
hopefully stuff is like flying by and I
would just keep in mind that you know
you wouldn't want to leave this up for
like a really really long time because
as it prints out to this little console
it saves everything and then it'll start
printing out like really really slow so
you really just want to develop short
time short term in here and close this
out but that
the whole point of this thing anyway but
as you can see I mean this is just
spitting out constant data and so what's
really cool about the Twitter API is
when you connect to it it's just it
literally is a stream of data you don't
have to continue connecting to it so
it's pretty cool not to mention let's go
ahead and cancel out of this you get a
ton of information like okay this this
is your tweet right from there all the
way the year I mean that's that's in the
same kind of stuff you get now obviously
you don't really want all of this stuff
but yeah you get that if you want it so
anyway that's the basic stream and
everything you need to do to connect to
the stream and you know choose a word or
whatever for that stream I will put this
the script right here on my website it's
pretty basic and also their example is
very close to this I've basically
learned from their examples so so yeah
so you can either get it off my website
or look at their example or whatever so
anyway hopefully that's helpful to some
of you guys in my future videos we were
going over some other things that we can
do with this Twitter feed but I did just
want to get everyone started off on some
good footing so as always thanks for
watching thanks for your support your
subscriptions and until next time